soir l'unesco a rassemblé à paris une
exposition de dessins d'enfants
particulièrement émouvant ces dessins
ont été réalisés par de jeunes
cambodgiens de 8 à 12 ans malgré leur
jeune âge ils ont été marqués pour la
vie par les atrocités de leur prime
enfance et il raconte il se raconte en
images
jacques collet 6 12 ans est le seul de
ses enfants a rapporté une image de paix
il est vrai qu'il a quitté le cambodge
avant l'arrivée des khmers rouges
les autres des enfants de son âge
témoignent à leur manière
bon
et
non
et oh
jean
des bandes
plus
monde
aujourd'hui les plus chanceux de ces
enfants sont repliés aux etats-unis au
canada ou en france mais il constitue
l'exception
les autres se trouvent encore dans les
camps de cao bang ou de saké au en
thaïlande
long
oh
non
écoutez